Believe it or not, the way you perceive taste is
in fact determined genetically a lot of times because it
has to do with your taste bud receptors. But not
all traits can easily be distinguished as visible or hidden.
>> That's true, and sometimes it can be really
hard to tell. Let's take Andy here for example.
>> Hi Andy.
>> Hi.
>> You see these beautiful big blue eyes?
[INAUDIBLE]
So the presence of these big blue eyes are obviously a visible trait.
>> But there's something about Andy that you
may not suspect, and we can't see on
the outside. If we had an x-ray machine,
and we looked inside the mid-section of his body,
we would be able to see that his
organs are actually flipped the opposite direction from most
people. This is a syndrome called Situs Inversus,
where all of the organs are flipped, left-right to
be the opposite symmetry.
>> Now you'd never know this about Andy because this
is a trait that's not easily visible by the unaided eye.
>> So why don't you actually think about two
traits you have, one that's visible and one that's
hidden, and enter them text boxes here. And if
you can, try to limit your respnses to one word.